That's it guys here
We are now hiring
Support
Annelise
He works from hampu
Dayship
Equipment equipment
Provided
Salary up on discretion
At Metro Manila ncr Luzon only to guys though
permanent
Of course the client will visit
From time to time
You have to show up with
engagement
Or activities to be done in
Company like team
Building or
What of course you have to show up
So visayas mindanao cannot
That's just sorry
Where is he guys let's overview
You are five thirty two to thirty
I think it's off net,
I don't know,
nothing is placed
He works from home full time
That guys
qualification
We are undergrads
The undergrad can be here as long as he graduates
With two to three years
Experience in
Customer
Support or Admin
Experience in
Handling
Collection is an advantage
He said it was for them
Just read that someone else has it
That's important
What are with you in this task in this role
Guys,
the tasks you will do are
Just screenshot the field
Operation
dev
Management
Work flow
Data
Management
Check and
Verification
Then last
Relicatories notice
And legal
Process
Additional
responsibilities
Maybe it's a screenshot or the video is posted
And guys if you are interested in support
Our analysis
Email me or resume
That's in the bio bye